[Musique]
ils sont près de 150 ingénieurs à
travailler au quotidien sur les
innovations au sein du groupe jc decaux
pour en parler nous sommes avec candice
marion bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors dans un premier temps dit nous
c'est les produits de demain ça ce qu'on
est derrière nous alors exactement ce
soit les produits de demain alors déjà
l'innovation elle irrigue le groupe tous
les métiers tous les collaborateurs sont
inspirés elle vient du modèle aussi
innovant le business model de jc de
conques et fournir des mobiliers et des
services et toutes les fonctionnalités
qu'ils soient entretenus gratuitement
pour les collectivités est financé par
la publicité et ce business model et
bien il nous inspire l inspirent les
collaborateurs mais il inspire aussi les
partenaires avec lesquels on travaille
on a des start up des petites de grandes
entreprises qui viennent me voir et
qu'ils veulent brainstorm est avec nous
sur ces nouveaux usages des services aux
collectivités ou notamment du digital
pour la communication extérieure et
ensuite on va développer très rapidement
des preuves de concept des proof of
concept en deux trois mois en terme de
faisabilité technique concerné la
solution on s'inspire de nouveaux usages
on travaille avec nos directions
marketing de direction design nos
partenaires qui nous complète
l'expertisé et on va proposer un concept
qu'on pourra ensuite expérimenté avec
les collectivités alors on est un
exemple parce que là on en a beaucoup
derrière nous alors je vous en avais
quelques exemples sur la partie digital
et services pour les pour les
collectivités par exemple alors le fil
très haut c'est un abri innovant qui va
améliorer la qualité de l'air pour les
usagers qui attendent sous la grue quand
on a imaginé ce concept on a scruté déjà
toutes les solutions technologiques on
pouvait avoir on est allé rencontrer des
partenaires des laboratoires de
recherche on s'est fait accompagner par
exemple par l'inra qui nous a convaincus
sur le fait que la végétalisation
permettait d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air alors quand on a quelque part qu
en ville ça améliore de quelques pour
cent mais lorsqu'on a une barrière
végétale ça peut améliorer jusqu'à 30%
et donc on a imaginé mettre sur les
toits cette solution de filtration on a
imaginé également sur une mousse parce
qu elle est légère et les vivas facile à
entretenir elle est donc très durable et
qui va faire une barrière
végétal aux polluants et permettent par
un système piloté de ventilation
d'améliorer l'usagé pour les personnes
qui attendent sous l'abri et aujourd'hui
on est en train de l'expérimenter avec
des villes on l'a installé dans deux
villes en france et on complète cette
expérimentation avec des premières
analyses qui sont réconfortantes sur les
souris dans quelle ville alors on
l'installé sur lille et strasbourg et
les premiers résultats là qu'on commence
à à dépouiller son succès sur lyon n'a
repéré deux tendances 1 pendant la crise
sanitaire une transformation digitale et
la transition environnementale là vous
venez de donner l'exemple que la
transition environnementale voulais te
prenais déjà en compte chez jc decaux
qu'en est il de la transformation
digitale alors la transformation
digitale également elle est très
présente vous voyez tous les écrans qui
nous entourent aujourd'hui on a toutes
les solutions de diffusion digitale
pourpre opposant communication
extérieure et qui complète complètement
les canal de communication à plus
classique sur lesquels on assure déjà du
temps réel de la contextualisations un
message au bon moment au bon endroit et
bien sûr toute la qualité de diffusion
et puis la sécurité des diffusions et à
côté de ça on va proposer également des
mobiliers plus innovants vous voyez ici
sur la droite avec des solutions de
micro led qui sont intégrés qui améliore
le contraste des solutions d'écrans
transparents de l'interactivité avec les
usagers et on propose là dessus des
solutions interactives c'est à dire que
la personne à l'usager va se retrouver
devant une offre de service gigantesque
arnaque il va pouvoir en fait manipuler
et interagir et qui va lui permettre
d'aller sur sur des services
merci candice marion je vous en prie
mais rappelle que vous êtes directrice
adjointe air et des nouveaux concepts et
produits innovants chez jc decaux et
c'est ainsi que se conclut ce sky échos
merci de l'avoir suivi vous pourrez
revoir cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur tv 78